backing up sensitive data, processing certain sensitive data, all sorts of things like this.
And so let's briefly talk about this concept of having a risk management.
We've talked through a ton of concepts now related to risk management.
How organizations have to identify their most valuable assets, identify all the risks associated with them.
How organizations have to identify their most valuable assets, identify all the risks associated with those assets, treat all those risks.
We've talked about all of this from the perspective of companies looking at their own systems and assets.
But what's incredibly common nowadays is that organizations outsource a ton of stuff.
They have a ton of different service providers that provide all sorts of often very sensitive and confidential services for an organization,
backing up sensitive data, processing certain sensitive data, all sorts of things like this.
And so let's briefly talk about this concept of having a risk management supply chain.
And what that simply means is that an organization needs to understand all the services that they have from different service providers,
and then conduct all of this risk management process that we've just talked about on their service providers.
So understanding what data is being outsourced, what processes are being outsourced, and what are the risks associated with that.
Now it's very common for instance that data is outsourced, and data is an extremely valuable asset to an organization.
So an organization needs to understand what assets being outsourced, what are the risks associated with that service provider,
and then how are they going to treat those risks.
And this is one of the big challenges with outsourcing is that when an organization outsources something to a service provider,
they now have far less direct control over the protection mechanisms that they can put in place,
they can put in place to protect that valuable asset, the data.
And really what organizations can typically rely on is not putting in place their own controls,
but rather requesting that the service provider put in place certain controls.
And so a big part of risk management supply chain is identifying the risks,
and then making sure that the contracts, the SLAs, the PLAs, whatever contracting vehicle the organization is using.
Make sure that it's explicitly stated in that contract, what controls the service provider needs to put in place to mitigate the risks that the organization is concerned with.
So that's the concept of a risk management supply chain.
One final piece we'll talk about in this risk management domain, and that is risk frameworks.
We'll talk about frameworks in more detail in domain 3, but for now frameworks are something that provide comprehensive guidance.
They allow organizations to have a roadmap, have a set of guidance that says, you know, for instance,
this director relates to risk management, if you want to put in place a risk management function,
are you just going to start with a blank piece of paper and try and make it up and hope it works well?
Well, you're going to go to a well established framework that says,
here's exactly how you put in place a risk management process.
Here's the different controls that should be in place.
Here's who should be accountable, responsible for what?
Here's how it should work.
So there is guidance out there that can help us figure all this out to not only build a new process,
but also to look at our existing process and say, how well does this align to industry best practices?
And you don't have to be an expert on any of the four frameworks we have listed here,
but just be aware that these frameworks exist and be aware of what you can use them for,
which is to help you build a new process or to evaluate an existing process.
And so NIST 800-37, ISO 31,000, COSO, COVID Risk IT,
these are just examples of risk frameworks.
And now you know we can use them for.